you can have money and a career you are
the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host this is the
ramsey show where we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
actual
amazing relationships dr john deloney uh
is my co-host today ramsey personality
number one best-selling author and big
time help in the relationship category
the questions you've got about mental
wellness we'll talk to you about your
career your money any of it the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five tom's
in portland maine hi tom welcome to the
ramsey show
hey dave thanks for having me on how's
it going better than i deserve what's up
so i called last summer i called into
your show and you gave me some advice
and i took that advice and i wanted to
was it any good it was it was great
advice i guess you wouldn't call back
maybe if i suck you wouldn't i was
hoping you were calling to complain man
all right
so we had a rental property that we were
debating on you know holding on to our
selling and your advice was to sell it
and we actually did just that we had 300
k 300k um in equity in the property and
we actually
sold it for much more than we thought we
could have and we walked away net about
500k from the sale
i'm so smart i'm glad i could help
now now the the primary purpose for the
the capital or the proceeds was to put
it towards our primary residence you
know in terms of an upgrade and whatnot
but we haven't had too much luck in the
market so my question to you is you know
now that we have the 500k do we
sit on that in terms of savings do we
short term invest it do we reinvest in
real estate and and try it you know over
the next year or two you know try and
make a splash in that sense or
what should our next move be with that
type of capital sitting in our savings
account at the moment
30 years of doing this the vast majority
of people who become wealthy do it
incrementally layer upon layer not with
splashes
okay
so you hit a really really good lick but
you've owned that house a long time
and you did it incrementally to get to
this 500k in your pocket okay so i'm
much more concerned with your next move
that with the money the money that the
money is available to do its main goal
which is move up in house when the
market calms down enough and you're
ready to buy you find up you sneak up on
a deal right
um
then i am that the
500k makes a bunch of money so let's
just play with some numbers for a second
this will help you okay
um
if you make um
ten percent of the money you make 50k
if you make a splash
which would be like woohoo
like unheard of you make 20 on your
money
you make another 50k
10 is kind of a pretty much you can do
okay 20 you just got either lucky or you
hit a hit hit a zone or you made a
gamble of some kind a much higher risk
play and you made 20 of your money so
the whole thing of going from almost no
risk to risk changes your picture in one
year by 50 grand out of 500 it doesn't
doesn't really take you anywhere because
you're not going to double your money
and i mean you could hypothetically i
mean you could go to vegas and double
your money but you could also but you'd
also understand the chance of losing it
all right so we're not that's not even
on the
you know on the list of possibilities so
within the realm of reasonable the
difference between making a higher risk
and a medium to low risk
doesn't change the equation enough to
screw with it
okay so what would i do if i woke up in
your shoes
i would park it all in a money market
account and sit and wait until i bought
a house
or
i might do half of it
in an index fund and ride the market
for two years
okay
now in my case i've got a lot more net
worth and a lot more
uh
liquidity cash and so losing some of the
money wouldn't
have as big an impact on my life so i'm
probably dropping it all
into an index fund as a matter of fact i
know i'm doing that because it's what i
do all the time with excess money i drop
it into an index fund until i find a
piece of real estate or find a project i
want to work on with it okay now here's
the thing index fund meaning in s p 500
is gonna do what the stock market does
stock market goes up ten percent
fairly normal you're going to make
around 50 grand stock market goes down
10 percent very unusual in a calendar
year
very unusual
but you lost 50 grand that's your play
okay you might make 50 you might lose
50. you're not gonna lose a hundred
unless you're like the world's worst
timing guy on the planet and you're not
going to make a hundred unless you just
catch a lucky break uh i wouldn't go
into it with that expectation so if you
want to play with a little bit and if
you want to cut those numbers in half do
what i said a while ago put 250 in a
money market and 250 in a simple uh i
think but the point is don't worry about
what this money is doing as much as
worry about having patience for the next
buy because you're going to mess up your
purchase
on that next house by more than you
could make if you get in a hurry or if
you put the money in something that's
stuck in you can't get it out so
i i'm an uneducated guy so help me here
so much no you're overly educated uh
about some about one little sliver of
the world you've got that
i got an advantage on you on one subject
okay so
if i put it in a money market account
that's earning two percent right now
and inflation's eight and a half am i
losing six and a half percent on that
money well is it is it technically a six
and a half percent loss yes
in purchasing power okay but here's the
thing he's not going to use it for
buying gasoline he's going to use it for
buying a house so what are houses going
to go up during the time okay that he's
making two percent and they're trying to
slow the housing i think
i think it's officially it's it's slowed
down i mean it's probably growing
instead of thirty percent of yours
probably growing seven percent a year
okay but points still made the house if
you're looking at a million dollar house
might go up five percent more than his
money went up okay
you know and so he's going backward with
the money market that's why i'd like to
put a little of it in there but still
that's not going to dictate nearly as
much as
don't get in a bidding war and that's
right run it up 200 grand
because you got house fever and your
wife likes the dishwasher and you got
obsessed about i got to do it now i've
got to do it now and you get all caught
up in the in the urgency though so it's
the tyranny of the urgency it's almost
yeah it's almost a
i i i like that almost as a
as a slowdown tax like just chill the
power is in the patience there you go
not in the investment so working with
law students they used to train it was
train them called the power of the pause
whoever talks last uh
loses right so just be quiet just be
quiet right and let people talk sales we
would ask a closing question and then
teach them to shut up stop talking just
stop talking about the power of that
silence yes
and you know in theater they teach you
the power of the pause same thing it's
the same thing there's a dramatic effect
if you're quiet my dad used to do
something we sell tomorrow on this show
but my dad used to do that
what happened john
i'd be like
nothing dad he'd just sit there and look
at me i'd say
i mean i didn't mean to man i mean it
was like it was it wasn't on purpose and
he had
he just fishing in a really rich target
rich environment
what happened that question got me in
more trouble
oh man john be patient john just tell me
what you did
that that list is long day this is long
i'm gonna let you be a little more
focused on your questions
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
so
[Music]
boy one of the things we've gotten to
enjoy the last few weeks is being back
in arenas back in large theaters
with a thousand two thousand five
thousand people and them cheering and
all there to learn how to change their
life and it is just so fun to be back
with human beings and i i know a lot of
you have been doing it a while like i
have and some of you you still haven't
been out in the public at all but it is
it is not good that man be alone it's so
fun picture all your favorite speakers
on one stage giving you the tools the
principles that create unstoppable
momentum that's smart conference it's
going to be three years by the time we
do this one it's going to be in dallas
saturday october the 22nd it will have
been three years since we did the last
one these are usually uh eight to twelve
thousand people uh this one's only going
to be about uh seven thousand people and
it is almost half sold out and it's in
october uh dr john deloney me all the
ramsey personalities plus craig and amy
groschel from life church are going to
be there it's absolutely incredible the
event passes started only 39 for an
entire day
of everything from relationships to
career to money to millionaires to
leadership it's all going to be marriage
it's all going to be talked about there
and when you leave the smart conference
after being there all day you're going
to be smarter
so check it out
ramseysolutions.com
events 39 tickets you cannot beat that
at all all right justin is with us
justin is in lubbock texas uh hi justin
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave how you doing better than i
deserve what's up
oh nothing much so i'm fairly new to
dave ramsey everything like that um i
just had a quick question i'm starting a
new job where i'm going to be traveling
a lot
they're going to expense it afterwards i
know you don't like credit cards but is
it worth getting a travel credit card
for this instance when they're going to
expense it out
well um
no but let me walk you through why okay
rather than just give you an answer the
um
number one i would ask that if they're
asking you to travel
on their money ask them to just give you
one of their cards
okay i mean i don't understand why this
big company needs you as their bank
needs you to front them money
uh i do understand it's because
corporate america has gotten rid of or
gotten away with letting travel ride on
their employees backs for 30 days for 25
years and nobody ever called him on it
and i'm calling him on it it's bullcrap
i don't send my people out that work
here and ask them to pay for the travel
where ramsey solutions makes money
uh well you're getting reimbursed well
why do i need why do i need uh you know
one of my guys that works here to be my
bank i've got the money
i need to just pay for his travel or her
travel right and so i first thing i do
is ask for it i'm just calling you out
corporate america you suck okay you're
riding on the back of your employees own
credit so here's the problem for you
justin two problems here's the pitfalls
and you can get away with it if you want
to get away with it but um
the pitfalls are number one i had a guy
had an mx card that was uh charged to
uh
that his company was reimbursing and
they asked him while he was in europe to
pick up twelve thousand dollars worth of
equipment and so he did uh put in a
suitcase brought it home and when he got
home and went to the office there's
padlock on the door they filed chapter
11. he ended up with 11 000 on his amex
card they did not reimburse him
uh and uh so that that that happens
sometimes uh and then the other thing
well it never happened with this company
yeah right and it's famous last words
but the other thing that happens more
often than that
is you've got this stupid thing in your
pocket
and um
i've traveled for 30 years
and um there's something about travel
that makes the human brain be stupid
you eat the wrong foods
you stay up too late
you
don't exercise
you
buy crap because you're bored
and that crap you can't put on your
expense report
and you end up with an extra 25 of
whatever of what you thought you were
spending at the you spent a thousand
bucks on the company and 250 on you
that you can't get reimbursed you end up
with credit card debt is what you end up
with
and i'm telling you because i've
traveled for a living and you know i
have to when i'm on the road like we're
back on the road we're back doing these
events and things i have to be
unbelievably diligent with my uh my
health my food intake my spending my
eyes
everything
where my eyes go i have to be very
militant about that because over the
years i've learned i just get fat sloppy
and broke when i travel
and it's just bad you know and because
hey justin let me give you let me give
you a third one i'll give you a third
one uh i did this once
when i was in college and i was uh
a student leader and so i would put all
the school purchases on my personal
credit card and the school just
reimbursed me and i thought i was
running a scam here because i was trying
to build up miles and all that kind of
nonsense that's a whole other call but
here's what happened
in the middle of the gap one month i um
my transmission fell out of or my clutch
burned out on my on my little cheap
toyota that i was driving
at the same moment i got a thousand
dollar reimbursement check
i did not have a thousand dollars or 700
bucks whatever cost to get a new clutch
and so i had that check i cashed it and
i went and got my car fixed
and that money did not go right back
into the pot to pay the credit card off
yeah and so the life life hit me in the
gap there and it i just didn't have the
discipline to do it very very few people
do that's why we don't play with them
and so what i do is i set up what i
suggest you do is you set up a separate
account checking account for just travel
only reimbursable expenses uh how much
do you think your travel is going to be
in a month
um i wouldn't expect it to get more than
four or five thousand dollars okay as
quickly as you can seed that one account
with three or four thousand bucks
okay and use a debit card
and then basically you're using your
money and then you're putting the money
back into your account that you've used
of your money from them that will cause
your brain to
uh function differently when you see
something in the airport gift store that
you think you need that you don't need
and because there's nothing in an
airport gift store that anyone actually
needs
hey and just so people understand what
dave was saying earlier um i go on the
road all the time doing private things
doing things with the team
before i leave an envelope literally
appears on my desk with travel cash in
it that is a
it's you putting money in my pocket for
travel yeah
if you're not someone that carries a
company debit card we french the cash
cash literally cash that's right and you
mentioned an entre an entree leadership
book once and i thought i'd never
thought of this before
people challenge you on giving your
employees company debit cards like how
could you trust them to do that
and your response in the book it's been
a year since i read it but it was
something to the effect of if you don't
trust somebody enough
don't hire them right if you can't give
them two thousand dollars they shouldn't
be right around your brand on there and
they pay them 150 grand what kind of
idiot are you you know i mean you can't
trust them with i mean you hired
somebody you can't trust with two grand
but you pay them 150 and they represent
your brand yeah oh my god it's dumber
than a rock yeah but corporate america
is dumber than a rock so i'll just tell
you they're just stupid bag of hair
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five devin's in
montana hi devin i'm short on time
what's up
hi dave and hi dr delony um i just got
to say i love your show dr deloney it's
great it helps me i'll talk to my wife
a lot awesome thank you much hey right
up against the clock what's your
question brother
um so
my wife and i uh we're curious when
we're finished with step three
should we
uh so she doesn't really like the house
that we're in i'm fine with it
but um
our house has almost nearly doubled in
value with the crazy house market hey
devon what's your question i'm wondering
is it wise to save a down payment
seemingly against increasing house
prices no or
pay off the house that we're in even
though my wife doesn't necessarily like
it pay off the house that you're in
because when you sell that house they're
going to magically write you a check and
give you all that money back at a
closing
you're not giving up the money when you
pay down on your mortgage you're storing
it in your home and it doesn't
accidentally get spent on a bass boat
then
pay down on the house in baby step six
in order then when you sell the house
and move up because your wife doesn't
like the house and son you are moving
you're moving yes it's just a matter of
when okay they're gonna give you the
money out of that house
[Music]
so
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage
zach and megan are with us hey guys how
are you good how are you good better
than we deserve good to have you where
do you all live dalton georgia ah just
down over the uh tennessee line then huh
yes sir welcome to nashville
how much debt did you pay off just about
fifty one thousand dollars good for you
and how long did that take right at two
years good for you and your range of
income during that time uh we started
out around 35 000 and we're up to about
128.
nice jump
okay so what kind of debt was the one
was the 51 000 uh we had some medical
bills some student loans and some auto
loans y'all were kind of normal
absolutely how long you been married
seven years okay
so uh i guess somebody got a job that
didn't have one or how did you go from
35 to 128 and i i graduated with my
bachelor's and got an uh real estate
license and insurance license actually
and she graduated with with her master's
degree in what
social work okay yep and were you
working before that yeah just part-time
jobs but i mean you took on a like a big
income then and then your income went
way up with real estate yes okay what a
time to stumble into that job man wow
excellent excellent excellent so what
happened that made you decide get out of
debt is good for our new young marriage
well we actually saw you live in 2015.
um
then we kind of did diet day for a
little bit diet day
we definitely didn't go all the way and
then um and so we got your book and then
later on actually went through the class
and uh when she came along our little
one a couple years ago that's when we
really decided we wanted to change the
family tree okay oh wait a minute this
is this just got real we got a baby we
got to like be grown ups and stuff yes
yeah so then you get the book off the
shelf and go no ish we're doing it
absolutely okay wow good for you who had
the conversation with who
that was probably
a little more me i would uh when i first
heard about you if i was working for
someone it was about eight years ago and
i was cleaning pools and it was this uh
i was riding around with the business
owner he was in this old broken down van
that was paid for and we listened to
your show every morning it came on the
radio and i was like this guy is crazy
and i did not i did not buy into it it
wasn't until i probably i got closer
into real estate and actually met a lot
of wealthy people that when i mentioned
your name they spoke highly of you in
the plan and i was like okay there's
definitely something behind this so
megan you just you just went like
like
were you not in at all huh no i was
definitely on board um it's
it's more just trying the discipline of
buckling down
i think
in
you know we were newly married and
um
i feel like like our first couple months
of marriage you know
everything comes at you at once
financial issues and you're trying to
navigate those and so
um
he came to me with this plan and
i just i just thought he was crazy but
i've always trusted him and here we are
seven years later and i'm glad that i
did so
what happened at the two-year mark the
real estate thing where you got into
those wealthy people when she was born
she's two years old okay yes and what's
your two-year-old's name ren wren okay
sweet very good good and zach are you a
a schemer like
and i say that not in a bad way but like
you're a pool cleaner and then like i'm
gonna do insurance i'm gonna do real
estate like he hopped around a little
bit he like you seem like you guys
always got a plan and i can imagine
sitting down be like all right i got a
new plan to get out of debt and you're
like i'm about as nerdy as it get i
started in taxes and then went to real
estate and then uh went from real estate
to insurance and i kept my real estate
license but um megan you must be the
funnest human being ever to counter
balance yeah oh yeah of course that's
awesome yes he's definitely the nerd on
the free spirit there we go definitely
okay good good all right so what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is you pay off 51 000 in debt in
two years
the the communication
for sure and
really just getting together on a plan
and giving that why why we're doing this
what the goal is and having that shared
goal like what what's our plan um i had
someone tell me
in real estate actually they were
planning on retiring at 55
and i was like how you doing that you
know are you planning on hitting the
lottery what what is that and he's like
no i mean i'm saving for retirement i'm
planning for retirement
and i just i i don't know it was just i
couldn't fathom that and so as i we got
on the plan and we started learning more
i was like okay if we get on board we're
um both of us are not 30 yet i was like
i think we can get this done and we can
actually retire early and so we started
talking about retirement at our early
age now and it's just i don't know
having that why is very important
it is so megan what do you say
what's the reason you all got out of
that i mean what is the thing you did
that got you out of fifty one thousand
dollars in debt um definitely discipline
um and and really working to be content
um i think
it's it's really hard you scroll through
social media and you see everyone doing
everything
um and so i think really being content
where we were um
and when just in our living situation in
um
just everything our jobs at the time and
being content in each season of life and
and working together and
[Music]
and convincing myself that i was content
i eventually became content so
yeah
it is a it's a
it's a spiritual state of being
that you that you have to aspire to you
have to want to do it it doesn't just
come on you like a you know like an uh
a weather pattern or something i mean it
you have to decide i'm going to be
content
and uh that's very cool i like that
coming from a free spirit in particular
that's it's very important yeah
and um because that's
um i'm the spender out of the two of us
sharon's the tight wad the saver and so
uh for me to stop spending required that
same exercise even though i'm a nerd
spender which is a little weird but uh
but the uh the spending part you know i
distinctly remember going to costco
and leaving with nothing
and it was like this personal spiritual
victory because i thought it was like a
federal law you had to spend 200 every
time you went in there like that's why
they check your little thing when you're
checking out you know make sure you
spent 200 bucks right
and so uh it was a breakthrough i i just
i mean i was like your age when that
happened and i suddenly went i don't
have to have stuff wow that's like a not
like i'm off drugs or something it's
pretty cool and so that's very that's
very insightful very well done good job
you guys very proud of you thank you who
were your biggest cheerleaders outside
the two of you
uh we definitely had family that
supported us through this especially our
grandparents our grandparents thought
this was a lot of common sense
and they're right i told them you made a
lot of money off selling common sense
they're right and it really is the
family behind that really did help us
for sure cool cool i i think
i know you all know this but it's
important for me to say it
i hope you all don't miss what you've
done for her
every she is not going to understand the
angst and that what do we do we can't we
owe this money and we can't make it this
month or inflation's crazy inflation is
going to be annoying it's not going to
be catastrophic for y'all right right
and the the the work y'all did those two
years to lay a sidewalk for this young
one to grow up on is it's family
generational trans transformational so
and from a mental from a mental wellness
standpoint the peace that's in their
house because you know you sit here and
talk about contentment there's a
different air in there the way the way
the the way the the
your child feels in the air of that
house is different because you're
content that's right and you hear that
saying that you just have to turn the
wheel one degree and eventually that car
turns all the way around you all turned
it much more than one degree but just by
altering the air a little bit to where
you all aren't bickering as much or
y'all aren't complaining or you're not
as frustrated or you don't have to go
have the new whatever or you don't have
to have another scheme just to survive
mommy's going retail therapy that's
right and dad's got another plan and
then another plan unbelievable and uh
but you don't have to do that and it
changes
the electricity in your home and man
what a gift you've given her thank you
all on behalf of parents everywhere
thank you just beautiful absolutely
fabulous we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you that's the next
chapter in your story for sure how
ordinary people build extraordinary
wealth how you can too just like those
wealthy people you talk to
and also a copy of total money makeover
for you and we're gonna give you a copy
i'll give you a one-year subscription to
uh to financial peace university and
every dollar as a ramsey plus
subscription and if you haven't been
through go ahead and go through it and
that'll help you get move on towards the
baby steps millionaire if you have been
through it give it to somebody that's
why we want to give it to you so you can
pass it along all right zach and megan
and ren dalton georgia 51 000 paid off
in two years make it 35 to 128. count it
down let's hear a debt free scream
three two
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
another family tree changed right there
because they
made different choices i love them
they're heroes man you guys are heroes
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225 i'm dave ramsey wendy is in
sioux falls south dakota hi wendy how
are you
i am fabulous today dave thank you so
much for taking my call sure um
just a straight shoot here um the point
of the call is my spouse and i are not
on the same page as far as getting on
this plan together
i do know that that it uh the full
reason is me
we've been together 20 years
i'm an alpha female i've always led i'm
the first born i've been a single mom
all of all of that just puts me the
powerhouse and my husband has been
amazing to endure all of that that comes
from me um
but i got gotten to a point this year
and something john delaney had said the
other day on the show is like sometimes
you're just in the corner just getting
pounded and pounded and pounded and just
waiting for the bell to ring for the
round so you can stand up and reset and
i just
shook with identifying with that this
year you're getting pounded or you're
pounding him
no she's getting well we're in life
we're both kind of getting pounded in
that way but in like the last year three
kids got married we empty nested my mom
oh i get you i get you okay it's not
between you and your husband it's just
life coming at you
okay oh no we're not gonna get into
pounding but we're gonna have a tough
conversation coming up and i just um i'm
actually two business days into i'm all
in on this ship and in these two days i
have
um contacted uh an open credit card that
i found that i had i didn't think i had
credit cards for over 25 years but i had
like a
furniture store card that had nothing on
it but it's sitting there open so i
called and canceled that i cancelled a
subscription today i'm having a
conversation with my boss about getting
more hours and changing my w-2 and i had
a conversation with the bank on friday
about a car that i potentially should
sell my husband is looking at me like i
am a crazy woman
and
he when i get in change is happening
mode
you can hear the lego bricks build a
wall right up in front of them give a
burr
and um
i've learned over the course of time
that if i just calm down
and
start doing
the thing
and prove that it's working without any
demand on him or any request of him
that he eventually swings around and
comes on board i do want us to be
together on this
and when i look at the numbers i bring
in 22-5
he brings in 55 000.
um when i look at my debt like i keep
looking at mine and his at the moment
just because
the swing around of us getting together
tell me how much debt your family has
i don't know for sure from his
perspective because i just found out
that there's more credit cards in his
wallet than i knew of
okay how long have you all been married
and
uh 15.
okay
and what would you if you were going to
guess how much debt is in his name what
would you guess
uh
if i think on his history
probably 15 on carts
medical debt what's out on your car oh
on the car
the car is
18 five
okay and what else what other kind of
debt is there um he has a car that had
that's only got like 3k left on it um so
the big picture we don't have tons but a
lot of it is secretive and
um you know i'm i'm all in i
here's the here's the super thing losing
my mom losing a grandparent
he has some sort of um
retirement through work
i do not i was self-employed for a lot
of years and then i worked in an
atmosphere where i was like oh he has
insurance no big deal
and hey wendy i'm
yeah
this is john you know what i hear
i hear somebody who has been
scratching and clawing and fighting for
a long long time
and
there's still a scared single mom
talking about that's exactly right
i'm still talking to a single mom
who does not know when the next shoe is
going to drop and this year a whole
bunch of shoes have dropped at the same
time
and
the way we often respond to all the
shoes dropping is we default to the
scariest moments our bodies have had to
endure and most of us start grabbing for
control i'm just like you
i come up with a new plan and i'm gonna
go see this happen come hell or high
water and i will swing and fight and
scratch and clone take everybody with me
and some people are a little wiser and
they stop and they
actually take a step back and scan the
landscape and say what's coming next is
this threat reels but not
but the next move forward cannot be
another control grab it can't be another
survival move it has to be a move
towards connection
so um another way of saying that is the
next move is a finesse move not a blunt
trauma move right
okay and i hear that in a finesse move a
finesse move might be that what if i
told you uh
90 percent of you winning with this
money thing five years from today is
dependent upon you all being on the same
page only ten percent of you doing all
this gyration you've been doing since
friday
you got to get him on the same page it's
paramount
because that's where that's where the
piece is going to come from that's where
the quality relationship's going to come
from and the data points tell us that
your your probability of overall wealth
building and success is so much higher
when you're working together
and and uh you might pull him into this
almost shame him into it by you getting
your act together and he doesn't but
generally speaking that doesn't work
what does work is to stop and just start
having conversations about the future
and go
hey um the single mom that used to be so
scared she couldn't eat friday that we
had beans and rice rice and beans and we
had ramen noodles and that was it is
activated down inside of me right now
because of all this crap that's happened
and i'm there's part of me that's just
scared and i'm just
driving towards some financial peace
because i've never really had any
and um
i i need some help with this and um i
know you think i'm a little crazy
because i am but i i i want to go
through this class and would you just go
through the videos with me
and and watch them with me and tell me
what you think
and uh
and if you can get him to sit down and
watch nine financial peace university
videos with you by the way if you can
get him to watch one i'll probably get
him to watch the rest because we're that
good
okay but um
but the uh get him to watch one or two
with you and then he'll start it'll
start to be his idea
and your idea together and what you're
doing is you're setting a vision
together for the future
instead of
well i got this figured out he
he's tired of me beating on him so he
can just sit over there and watch while
i go do it right until he wakes up
that's just highly inefficient
there's no finesse in that play
and wendy i'm going to one-up ready
i would love
for you to follow that conversation
with
the truth that y'all have been married
for 15 years but y'all haven't been
married y'all have been co-managing a
house for 15 years
ed if you sat down and look across the
table from him and say i want the next
15 years to be different i want us to be
together
and that means i'm going to have to
change and i'm sorry for running over
you for 15 years
and i'm gonna have to be different will
you will you practice that with me and
by the way you're not perfect either bub
and
let him be open about some of the
challenges he has because really this is
about
man
dave nailed it man this is about y'all
coming together
i found the greatest way to come
together is to i'm going to put my
shield and sword down first and that
means he may kill you he's not going to
but that means he could hurt you and you
haven't been hurt in a long time because
you haven't let nobody that close you
haven't let anybody that close right
you're right okay
i i i i really like you you're brave
you're a warrior princess but um
but yeah but this is this one's gonna be
one at the diplomacy table not with the
sword in the shield
all right will you do that for you
i will do that for us there you go you
hang on i'm going to put you in
financial peace university as my gift
and cost you a thing kelly's going to
pick up i'm going to sign you up for
your subscription
and the only sale you've got to make
is to get his butt in front of a tv for
an hour that's always the only sale
you're going to make you can do that
my wife has gotten me to watch some
things on tv that are just amazing like
downton abbey i mean she can do sharon
in the doubt now if she can do that then
you can get him to watch us
that was i lost my man card right then
this is the ramsey shop
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships dr john deloney ramsey
personality is my co-host today
guys one of the benefits one of the
things that happened to me about 15 or
20 years ago i started getting to meet
people
that were way smart and uh
wise and
were really speaking into certain areas
of
life
and in a way that just blew my mind and
um so in a sense i
i kind of went hunting on behalf of all
you guys that are listeners and i found
some of the best
teachers and thought leaders on certain
subjects
and uh
and i said about the business of making
them my friends and they are and so
consequently uh hitting here uh beside
me along with dr john delony ramsey
personality but
meg meeker and i have been friends now
for 15 or 20 years a long time i guess
it has been yeah and i've done lots and
lots of events together meg has been in
smart conference she's been on this show
many many times and it all started from
a group of guys i was going through a
bible study with and we were all read a
book most of us had daughters that were
grown or almost grown by them but the
book was called strong or is called
strong father's strong daughters it was
a new york times bestseller and i
reached out to meg and said hey i'm a
huge fan and um she's like well i never
heard of you so um
and uh so she came on the show and uh
then we sold a whole bunch of her books
and so now she's heard of me and
[Laughter]
so she's coming down she's down here
from michigan her hometown hanging out
in nashville today launching a brand new
uh course a master class called strong
father's strong daughter's master class
and it all stems from the thesis and the
subject matter the nuanced subject
matter of the entire book itself and
welcome back my friend thank you for
having me dave so good to have you
i want to set the table for all of our
listeners who might have just joined us
for the first time in the last month or
two months or whatever
um the
thesis
the underlying theme of strong father
strong daughters is there's a huge
correlation
between women who succeed in every part
of their lives and their relationship
with their dad you bet and i think it's
a very um
um relationship i think that fathers
today and it's worse than you know when
you and i started talking back in 15
years they're so maligned they're so
marginalized they're told by our culture
nobody needs you your kids don't need
you you know um just sort of step out of
the way
and the exact opposite is true we need
good dads good men to step up and engage
and particularly with their daughters
now and so that's why i really believe
the message of the book is more
pertinent and powerful now than it was
15 years ago yeah it's huge and and the
data that you presented in the original
book and as again in this class
that just backs up that idea yeah is uh
that is amazing the the the uh negative
behaviors of
daughters young women and the positive
behaviors really does
man it can really be uh
changed by the relationship with their
dad absolutely and the interesting thing
is and i need fathers to realize this
you don't need to overhaul your
personality you don't need a phd in
psychology by implementing some very
simple steps and strategies you can
dramatically change your daughter's
outcomes success relationships across
the board and fathers don't know this
and that's my job and my mission
is to really grab hold of fathers and
say if you only realized how important
you are in your daughter's life and your
sons as well
your life would never be the same
that's ringing so true to me um
i know this i do this for a living and
i've got a six-year-old daughter and so
i can talk theory all day and i can talk
all the classes
it is really hard to feel like i've got
value when my six-year-old puts her
hands on her hips and says no dad i
don't wanna talk to you yeah it's just
simpler for me to say cool man your
mom's gonna make sure you're fed i'm
going outside
and to i here's i don't have a tool box
i don't have a tool kit i don't have a
picture of what leaning back into that
looks like and worse than that you have
a whole culture that tells you that
you're doing screwing her up that you're
not even supposed to be there yeah and
so i know that and i'm still saying i
should probably just i'm going to back
out of this thing right and i've got to
fight that impulse and so i'm so glad
you're having this conversation
uh if if i can't and i don't say this in
a self-serving way
but if i struggle with this i'm just
thinking of my buddies who
haven't sat in grad school for the last
20 years and worked with families
i can't imagine how difficult that is
yeah well you know you take a divorce
dad who's
living on his own and he's having
daughters over the weekend and he just
feels very insecure or you have fathers
whose daughters are estranged you know
and incidentally i'm talking about
daughters who are 4 to 44 to 84 every
daughter wants more of her dad she wants
more time if she had a good relationship
or she wants more healing if they had a
tough relationship but really the strong
father strong daughter master class is
that tool book you know in the book
strong father's strong daughters i
really tried to show dads why they're so
important i wanted them to understand
how their daughters see them which from
what i've heard over the years is just
transformational for men
but then they said okay now what do i do
you know i get why i'm so important
but now how do i live that out with my
daughter and you know i got so many
letters from men over the years i said
okay here you go so that's what the
master class is it's all online
and it's very very user friendly it's
basically a lot of short
videos from me saying
here's here's what your daughter sees
here's what you do here's who you are to
her like you're her first love which is
true you're her hero you are the most
important man in your daughter's life a
lot of moms don't want to hear that but
it's true
my job is to speak for kids you know my
job is to speak for kids and that's why
i'm so passionate
on
helping dads understand their value and
how critical they are and it's you know
what it would change the country if dads
understood how important and powerful
they are
our schools would be different our
neighborhoods would be different the
country would be safer
if we just elevated our dads and that's
that's my goal it's really as much of a
movement as it is teaching
that's powerful yeah powerful so there's
ten chapters in the book and um
each section in the course talks about
one of the chapters exactly ten courses
so so well yes that's right and each um
chapter there's two uh videos from
either short and the first video
summarizes the point of the chapter the
second video says okay here's things
three things to do you were always about
that okay mate tell them what to do tell
them what to do it's the way a guy
thinks i'm fine with philosophy but men
need to say okay now tell me what to do
okay do i touch or do i not touch her
when she doesn't want to hug me do i
keep on hugging her do i back out and so
that's what i do the practical steps so
that's how each chapter is broken down
so there's 10
um 10 chapters and 20 videos and then i
have some helps you know some written
things just to remind men you can find
all of it at
meekerparenting.com we're going to come
back with some of those practical how
to's with dr meg meeker pediatrician
best-selling author the material we're
talking about strong father's strong
daughters master class
meekerparenting.com
check it out there you will be glad you
did
yeah
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
four
three
[Music]
[Music]
joining me this half hour dr meg meeker
best-selling author the book strong
father strong daughters has now been
made into a masterclass at
meekerparenting.com
m-e-e-k-e-r-parenting.com dr john dolone
ramsey personality
is my co-host
meg when we start talking about the
power that a dad has to speak life and
to
a daughter to make her more confident
less chance of being sexually
promiscuous
less chance of being on drugs a higher
chance of graduating from college all of
these are data points that actually come
up
absolutely and you know i was trained as
a physician
to learn how to read studies and to
always pull great data and to work
around that you know we don't just come
and sort of make things up and say this
is how i feel and this is important
everything i write has to be
backed up by solid data and the data is
overwhelming on how important fathers
are in their daughter's lives and their
sons
but our culture ignores it they just
motor over and if you popularize a
concept on the internet or social media
like we don't need dads you know um
women don't need ads we can we can raise
great kids without dads that becomes
sort of the mantra of the day but it's
wrong and people in their hearts know it
dads know it but nobody comes along and
says this is how you're important this
is why you're important this is how your
daughter's life will change if you
implement these things
nobody tells them that because it's
really it's very much in vogue and uh in
our culture to just beat the heck out of
dads
i'm done with that i'm sick of it
you get standing ovations at our events
when you say that too by the way
people go because everybody it rings
true in the heart
because no one is out there saying
anything except you know all the men in
commercials on television are idiots
right all the men in the sitcoms are the
weak sister they're the idiot yeah
they're the uh the eight-year-old
smart alec is in charge of the house and
the sitcom and it's like uh didn't grow
up in the house i grew up in nor my kids
grew up in because i got to tell you the
inmates weren't running the asylum at
our place 3713 faulkner drive that
wasn't the way it was happening i'm just
saying yeah so can can we flip this
around
and
i i have found with the men i work with
i can talk about the hey you guys need
to be doing this and this and this
and often i get a yeah i know i know
i often have to reverse that and i hate
being this way but often i have to say
if you don't
right here's the consequence and this is
a data-driven consequence this isn't me
making it up like you said there is more
likelihood that yes right and
it's it's this incredible power or
strength if you will
dads can hurt their kids
by acting certain ways or not acting
certain ways being absent or
you know delightful
or they can capture the imagination of
their kids and absolutely as we talked
about on the show just change the family
tree and change the family legacy what's
one or two things that dad sitting at
home right now an over-the-road trucker
an electrician who's listening to this
who's gonna get home at six o'clock
tonight what's a couple of things dads
can do
instant like you can go do this you can
go flip these one or two switches and
start making a difference there's so
many doors there's so many but this
here's what it starts you know every
daughter needs affection and attention
and affirmation so the minute you walk
in that door she's going to be scouring
you for clues about who you are does my
dad see me so you you come home put the
stupid cell phone down you know regroup
get into your home mode not your
business mode you walk into the kitchen
or wherever your daughter is and you
look at her you touch her on the
shoulder and say i'm so glad to see you
boom
changes her evening
now she's safe now she's insecure she
can go about doing what she wants to do
if you walk in the kitchen you ignore
her like she's not even there you're
texting somebody or talking to somebody
else she becomes invisible and she feels
that she's not valued
and it's been my experience that she
will spend and boys do this too but
she'll spend the rest of her life
figuring out what's wrong with her why
exactly what did i do to make him not
want to see me exactly because her idea
is that she is she's responsible for
everything so if you come in and you're
mad you're angry at her it's her fault
yes you know if you take that last
meeting of the day home to greet your
daughter with it and and you know
unfortunately we bring our um our
problems at work home you know the kids
don't ask to um you know be yelled at or
angry but if you have an argument with
your boss which i know nobody at
ramsay's solutions no nobody argues here
we argue for a
living and you go home and you didn't
want to argue with your boss because you
don't want to lose your job then you
walk in the house and you have to let
all this anger out where does it go it
spills onto your five-year-old or your
10-year-old and um those dynamics
are are set up in the family and the
daughter sees dad's upset i did
something wrong i better go away yeah
boom just like that and over and over
then she begins to realize if dad
doesn't think i'm important you know i'm
really not important
but if she she gets these clues
throughout her life even in early years
man dad really thinks i'm something that
girl's going somewhere
complete it's that
simple yeah and that's what the master
class is all about you know you know
i've talked about this before i had the
unusual blessing of working with
teenagers when my kids were born
at the church and so i was reading all
this youth ministry
materials there was a guy named josh
mcdowell out there writing
and uh he he said uh as a dad of teenage
daughters you will either hug your
daughter or someone else will you you
bet you bet yeah
exactly because their need for male
attention is so primal and so real and
it drives them and fathers don't see
that fathers see themselves as well you
know i guess i'm important i should do
this but mom's really got this you know
because mom understands daughters i
don't understand daughters so i'm going
to kind of um i don't even understand
mom how can i understand daughters
i know that's the next masterclass dude
that's why it's called a master class
that's why i'm here with two guys yes
hey can we say
i think a common mistake men think get
is that energy that connection is
sexualized and it's not it's not but
there's a difference between that sexual
energy and connectivity right and
affectionate right and so when you tell
dads you need to get down on a knee and
let your daughter see her and touch her
on the face and touch your shoulders and
say i see you and i love you and it's
not a romantic gesture it's a
connectivity right and daughters know
that of course they do that it's the men
that i see they get nervous and
back away from that here's when they get
really nervous john is when she turns 12
or 13 or 14 and he walks in to hug her
and she's standing there like she's got
porcupine needles all over her deck and
dad goes oh okay she doesn't like me
anymore she's becoming a teen i'm going
to back out
wrong
wrong
you know and that's the time
step in but do it differently you know
don't give her a bear hug in front of
her friends or anything that's when you
in the evening you go up at the end of
the day you sit and just on you sit on
your bedroom floor how was your day i
haven't seen you you're gonna go change
the oil in the car hey will you come in
with jump at the car
i haven't i haven't talked to you i had
i don't know how your week is just come
with me
that changes the kids
life
and dads don't get that yeah
hmm
it's it's
but with a little bit of instructional
sort of willingness boom and it's not
hard and you know here's the thing you
and i've talked about this too we've
even talked about on the air one of the
guys said take your little daughters on
date nights
okay so we get all dressed up and i
would take them to a fancy restaurant do
a movie or something i did that like
i'm
guessing
five or six times each in their entire
lives
and if you ask these grown ramsey women
they will tell you i dated them every
weekend every weekend because it got i
got so much credit for so little effort
the exponential growth of that in their
head is unbelievable i did the same
thing with my dad i mean he would take
me out in heart you know we would we'd
have coffee or hot chocolate on saturday
mornings and he probably did it three
times to me did it you know every
weekend
but that's the power of a dad in a
daughter's life and that's what men need
to see is you don't need to um do things
a lot
you don't even need to be great at what
you're doing you have to be rich no just
try we did this the other day um we
i've been hanging out with east
tennessee hillbilly a lot lately and uh
who would that be i don't know and i had
two turkey decoys out in the front yard
and somehow i don't understand my
daughter and i ended up playing dragon
protector with some sticks that were
swords or whatever and i don't know i
still don't fully understand what we
were doing did you kill the decoys we
were protecting the decoys from some
wool dragons or something i don't know
where her head was but
i heard her tell my wife
we spent there about an hour running
around and rolling around the grass and
she told my wife at bedtime when she was
reading her book she said today was the
best day of my life and i thought it
cost me an hour
an hour and i have a chapter protect and
defend her wow
every
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
ten
nine
eight
seven
six
five
four
three
[Music]
if you are a business or an hr leader
you know your employees are dealing with
a lot
our employee wellness team smart dollar
just did a study and found out that
after living through one of the toughest
times in history
60 percent
of employees say their mental health has
gotten worse half say their mental
health keeps them from doing their job
to the best of their ability
good leaders take their employees mental
wellness seriously
and because it's good for you your team
your business when your employees are
healthy
mentally
so give your employees a way to deal
with their stress and put them on a path
to care for their mental wellness john
dr john deloney my co-host today has the
anxiety relief checklist that gives your
employees simple steps that they can
take to relieve their anxiety so they
can start bringing their full selves to
work it's free
to get dr john dolone's anxiety relief
checklist for your employees go to
ramseysolutions.com
anxietychecklist again that's
ramseysolutions.com
anxietychecklist okay john i got anxiety
reading that um the uh
an anxiety relief
checklist there's a lot going on so i
got anxiety and i want relief and this
is a checklist on what to do to get
relief yeah there's just some some man
we just we over complicate anxiety most
of the time and so it's something you
can just walk through and say ah okay
okay
um
so it might be a season where you ate
something that was bad it might be a
season where you're exhausted you might
be a season where you owe some people
money and your finances are a mess and
the inflation is not annoying it is
catastrophic for you and your family
right so you can walk through these
things and say which ultimately we're
gonna get to the bottom of what can i
control here what can i cannot control
and then how are we going to get after
it
go to ramseysolutions.com
anxietychecklist it will help your team
for those of you that are in leadership
it is completely free our question of
the day comes from blinds.com find out
for yourself why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings free samples free
shipping and new promos all the time
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey to get the best deal so dave i'm
gonna tell you i cheated and i read this
one ahead of time oh it may be my
favorite ever well you'll have to read
it for everybody else now i know i can't
wait
today's question comes from jason in
illinois jason writes
my question is about income from a side
hustle
i recently began sports betting and have
built up a bankroll of about four
thousand dollars so his side hustle is
gambling
my wife and i have about 55 000 in total
debt excluding the house we earn about
61 grand a year i'm a saver said the
gambler
my wife is a spender we don't have a
budget and need an additional 500 bucks
to cover our bills for the month
i have agreed to withdraw this my
favorite sentence i've ever read on the
show
i have agreed to withdraw 250 bucks a
month from my sports betting account to
help cover our shortage but my wife
would prefer i liquidate the account
dave what should i do
oh man this is a real person
oh man there's a human out there that
really asked that
if we don't say something stupid we're
gonna be employed forever
[Laughter]
forever
oh man all right so i'll jason you're
not jason you're not from the south or
around the south we would say bless your
heart bless your heart so number one
uh gambling is not a side hustle
[Laughter]
because you're not that good you
prideful arrogant little jerk it's an
addiction
it's an addiction number two you're not
a saver
you're a
gambler i
i i
sometimes
like this guy sounds like he's he thinks
he's not playing
he he thinks he's so good at it there's
a guaranteed income yes that's what i
meant by you arrogant prideful little
jerk that's what i was saying
yeah he there's an arrogance that goes
with this type of addiction
that he thinks he's the exception of the
rule and he thinks that
mgm grand
was built
by santa claus instead of by bettors who
lost their butts exactly caesar
right in his palace yes
so liquidate this immediately all four
thousand
put all four thousand dollars close all
of your sports betting accounts
take your wife out for a cheap meal and
say you are sorry and that you have lied
to her and you've been dishonest and
you're gonna go get help
and
then go get a second job
that you work for and that pays you
every time and you earn money and stuff
and never say you have a 250 a month
side
betting account no no no no he has four
thousand dollars that's his money that
he earned and he was going to bless his
little wife by allowing her to use 250
of his 4 000
because he's that kind of business
account he's a sweet guy that way
no more separate accounts now you hear
all the sarcasm folks i just want to
make sure you heard sarcasm in there
because that's uh it's important that
you heard that
you arrogant little self-centered
unbelievable
you need help son just don't say it
because you're going to get us canceled
no i'm not going to get canceled i own
the show how can i cancel me
that'd be nice of you no i was kidding
listen man you're not you're not
i don't know how to say this you're not
well i i
a buddy of mine who's a pastor here in
town walked me through
the increase in sports betting oh yeah
in tennessee yeah
astounding period no the number one
fastest growing addiction in america
online porn number two online gambling
and most of it is sports but i didn't
see the money and we have we have a cool
dude named caesar doing commercials give
me a break here
unbelievable the amount of money it is
funny i have talked to 25 people in the
past
handful of months that are lost their
families their businesses their jobs
their their life is done and it's all
because he thought he was cute betting
football
and it starts there it's just i'm sorry
you're not cute dude and you're not cute
looking at porn either i'm not it's not
funny
it's not funny you're a wuss
and you need help need help and you've
got you are messed up
uh this is all you know and you could
you just read your own email how messed
up you are you have four thousand
dollars and your wife who is the only
person on the planet who actually thinks
you're cool
wants some money
and you are going to give her 250 of
your 4 000. i want to choke you
your job is to serve your family not
your sports betting addiction
okay
the show
there is no got there is no data that
says that people who sports bet end up
wealthy as a matter of fact there's a
ton of data that indicates that the
person that you're betting with ends up
wealthy and you end up with nothing
there is no data that says that when you
um
act like that you own everything and you
are throwing
coins but what's the thing for mary
poppins tuppence to the poor
you're throwing tuppence to the poor
like your poor little wife we're going
to give her a tuppet or whatever that
was i can't remember that she's not a
poor little wife though dave she's the
spender yeah she's the spender he's the
saver see dude you are so there's so
many
here's the thing about this email jason
some people
quite a few in fact can have a one or
two drinks they can go to dinner have a
drink have gloss wine have a cocktail
um
some though can't
ever again
some people can get together with their
buddies and put 25 bucks in on something
or you know go to vegas once a year
you my friend probably are not that
person and so i'm suggesting you might
have to close this account and never
open it again uh
not maybe you do
ever because the language you're using
indicates you've got all kinds of issues
that are having and do the sports
betting that's right and the sports
betting is going to get exasperated i
see it all in the language yes
you have to call somebody and say i'm
not okay you're not okay you're a sick
puppy
gosh i hope we weren't unclear
[Laughter]
so it sounds like we're making fun of
you because we are okay
and i'm not so much i we are no you are
you're like this is the worst email i've
ever had you know people like this are
on the planet we're always going to be
employed that's true you are making fun
of him but i mean here's the thing dude
it's so you're so it's so messed up that
it's impossible to not make fun of it
and give you a loving kind gentle answer
with a straight face without being
sarcastic because it's so everything in
this is so freaking absurd that's that's
it's the absurdity so put the addiction
aside this is the way you treat your
wife is absurd the way you
the way you think that this is a side
hustle is absurd
[Music]
the way you think this is saving
you're a saver it's absurd
everything in here is absurd and so the
absurdity has to be addressed and we're
doing that with sarcasm and humor go get
a job we just don't know what else to do
go get help go get a job
[Music]
dr john delaney ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america we're glad you're here karen is
in phoenix hi karen how are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
i've been wanting to hear that listening
to you for a long time appreciate
everything that you have taught me well
thank you and my question my question is
my husband and i have owned a small
vending business soda and snack machines
for about 20 years
i'm 72 he's 66.
for the last couple of years we feel
that we're getting tired of
of the
the um the physical aspect of this
business the listing and the you know
carrying and whatnot how many machines
you got
we have about 35 machines
we do it all ourselves him and i
um some of the accounts we only have to
service once a month some of them once a
week some of them every two weeks
but we've done it all ourselves
we earn we net about 2500 a month from
this business
after our expenses
now we have someone who wants to buy it
he has offered us 60 000
for the business
that
including because we have about 10 000
in inventory
i'm figuring that the
machines are worth about 30.
i have net income 30 machines are worth
30 and the inventory about 10 000.
and he offered us 60
but then we have to pay 10 000 to the
broker
so that would leave us
with 50 000.
now we're not sure whether we should
sell it or not we
we don't have a lot we have we sold our
house
two years ago
before the big rise
in in real estate
so we put the money we put 300 000 into
a retirement account into mutual funds
and we have about 75 000 in cash
okay let me give you let me give you a
couple of technical numbers
that will uh help you with the analysis
okay okay
there there's uh three different ways to
put a value on a business
one is what's called book value
which is if you just closed the business
and sold off the stuff in this case the
machines and the inventory
which would be 40 grand okay you could
do that right and you think you'd get
about 40 grand the machines are worth
about 30 you thought right
yes okay yes you don't get to do that
and
calculated on top of that with the
income
you either create you either sell it for
book which is the worst case scenario
and um
you put the money in your pocket that's
in the machines you sell the machines
you sell off the inventory or you run
the inventory through the machines
whatever and you just end up and you
close it up okay so that that would
match you somewhere around 40. uh
another way to do it is a a gross
multiplier which i would have no idea
how to do in this business
but in some industries you take your
gross revenues
uh which is before all of your expenses
before any expenses and you just have a
multiplier like times two or something
or times one or one and a half or
but but i don't even know what that is
in this world it really doesn't apply
much in small business the third way the
most accurate way is after you paid
someone to do the work
what would you net
times
four or five
four would be if the person wanted a 25
percent rate of return five if they
wanted a
um
[Music]
if they wanted a uh 25 or four if they
want 25 return five if they wanted 20
return okay so if we did that we would
say okay you're netting 30 if you paid
someone
20 000 a year to run all of this for you
you didn't touch it and you put 10 in
your pocket as the owner
not as the label okay not as you're
getting paid for labor and be an owner
but when you're selling the business so
if you said ten thousand times five
would be 50 times four will be 40. uh
bring and that's probably not that far
off really you probably take 20 grand to
pay somebody do what y'all do
right you might net somewhere around the
10 range so the 50 is a good offer is
what i'm telling you
okay
i would take it
now would you here's a fun idea just for
a twist you wanna throw a twist in it
yes yes i'm open i'll take it and i get
to keep two of the machines my choice
okay and locations okay can you take the
two sweetest machines of the 35
and you all keep servicing them so you
don't get too bored sitting at home and
looking at him
exactly
we thought about that
we thought we were going to sell them
off individually and then just keep the
two best oh okay you could do that too
but yeah i'll do the 50 that's really
less than i want if you let me keep my
two favorite machines
and location with the machine what would
those net you okay
those would let us um
let's see the two best about
400 500 a month yeah
yeah just a little something to do just
a little tickle and later on you can
sell them if you want to
right you can sell them later on again
if you want to
yes maybe even to the show
the same guy does that feel good you
want a salad i could hear it in your
voice
yes well i do i mean but you're tired of
lifting cases of cokes
yes my husband's tired of lifting cases
and i'm tired of lifting candy bars no
they're heavy yeah they are i love
lifting candy bars
[Laughter]
i love lifting candy bars john this is
not to eat it's to put in the machine
see that you couldn't be in the business
you would eat the inventory do this
business food eat the inventory this is
like selling drugs for me no
i could never do this
oh he would
you gain a lot of weight in this
business we want to do other things we
want to do other something different so
okay that's a that's a good id offer i
don't think i don't think the uh 50 000
net to you is a bad deal at all
okay
just based on the numbers you gave me if
i there may be something i don't know
there may be something i'm missing but
it sounds fairly accurate mathematically
and it does sound like it's time
which is the other part of the equation
cash up front no payments
no you're not carrying back financing
cash on the barrel head i want to see
benjamin's in your bo in in your in your
deposited into your checking account
real money she mentioned something an
agent and i've never heard of that
business broker okay and all they do
they like a real estate agent for
business oh they sell businesses okay
for a commission
it's not that unusual that's great huh
and especially around something like a a
a it's got a route like a tool business
it's got a route okay or a uh um
or a vending machine business has got a
route something like that business
brokers jump all over that stuff
so
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money krista is
in virginia beach virginia hi krista i'm
short on time go fast
hi how are you thank you for answering
my phone call my question is
student loans i am roughly 360 thousand
dollars didn't want that good lord are
you a doctor or a lawyer i'm
i'm a pilot you're a pilot what do you
make yes sir
um right now i'm currently in the
military so i'm making about 75 000 a
year
why didn't the military pay for you to
be a pilot
so they do offer that program but i was
the first one to go to college in my
family so we were very uneducated about
the process and i was not sure that was
even a thing until i joined the military
so now here i am and i'm not really sure
what to do or how to pay for this
because we already have a fixed interest
rate of about 2.5
being in the military and i've deferred
it as long as i can and unfortunately
it's
at the moment where i have to pay and
it's right are you married
no sir okay when do you get out of the
military
my contract is for eight years
starting when
starting about two months ago you have
to finish flight training which takes
about three years and then your contract
begins so i'll be in for about 11 years
by the time i can get out
oh man
and like
my mother like
she knows she helps as much as she can
but i'm trying to avoid no your mother
can't help you with 350 000 honey
you're going to be living on nothing and
barely paying the bills until you get
out of the military i think hang on
we're going to try to set you up with
one of our financial coaches and maybe
they can see something i'm not seeing in
the initial
distressing two minutes of this phone
call we want to help you but um well you
just trapped yourself it sounds like kid
you can get out of the military you need
to go commercial so you can make some
money
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king in the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
open phones this hour as we talk about
your life and your money the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five my co-host today dr
john deloney ramsey personality number
one best-selling book
land uh we're my number one best-selling
author of the number one best-selling
book i'll get that spit out correctly
here in a second you talk and you call
in talk we'll help you the phone number
is triple eight eight two five
five two two five allen is in louisville
kentucky hi alan how are you
hi dave and john i'm doing better every
day what an honor to talk to both of you
you too sir how can we help
well i'll be quick i'm not here to waste
anybody's time i'll give you the context
and then the question
um
24 married got one child make 60 000 a
year in union construction right now
however i'm on total temporary
disability roughly three months ago i
was buried in a building collapse and
buried totally alive
through the work of the co-workers and
firefighters that got me out within two
hours and saved my legs within five
minutes
so i'm back home i'm out of the
wheelchair i'm in therapy
there i still got probably another four
weeks until i start doing some light
duty stuff
um broke leg and shoulder and had a
small brain bleed was on the ventilator
for a little bit
some other
other stuff but um the questions i've
got for you i've retained lawyers for
other stuff but it kind of revolves
around if and if there's anything ruled
negligent which is kind of what you're
thinking i'm sure
um
is
as far as the settlement wise you know
how long do i wait i'm renting right now
um
you know i don't have fancy cars i got
what i need i've i was in baby step two
right now i've got about five thousand
on savings
and i've got 2 500 and past medical debt
obviously everything's being taken care
of as far as i'm on i'm on disability
and then everything's being covered by
workers comp just those main two
questions is just you know how long do i
wait if there's a settlement and then do
i pay off that 2500 that i've gotten
past medical debt um i was in the baby
step two i've been through ipu i've used
your elps for everything from my taxes
to my insurance i've got disability
insurance i felt like it's done you've
been through well
[Music]
adventure that you've been on man
right how long ago how long ago was the
accident
well it was in end of february so it's
been just over three months wow
i've been walking here for about two
weeks so you're up walking now
yes yep up walking i've got surgery
coming up here in two or three days
they're gonna take a screw out of my
knee that's kind of messing with my walk
and i should get a little better but
that should be the end of that it says
you're a tough motor scooter how are you
managing the pain
um well uh or off of percocet so we're
just long traveling all now so we're
never going back right
that's that's the plan yeah no no no no
we're never going back we're never going
back right
correct correct there you go that makes
buildings fly yeah yeah good for you
yeah the percocet before that cutting
means a little hard on you and dilaudid
and all that yes
this yes
yeah you got messed up
sorry man i'm glad you're lucky man i'm
glad your little girl's got her daddy
with her
right
so uh yeah it's just i couldn't find
anybody on youtube that had the scenario
that i did outside of maybe inheritance
questions but i'm just looking for some
counsel
huh um it's early
to have this discussion because right
now i'm just happy you're up walking
around i'm out of breath listening to
you
the um but but
you know a year from today two years
from today five years from today
what are you what are you have you
thought that far out on what you're
going to be doing for a living
well i i continued as far as the
relationship with the employers you know
still been great they you know they're
grateful for everything it you know it's
still under investigation to exactly
what happened i was the only one that
was their building that fell in
if we're a general contractor and i'm a
union carpenter
and we're working on a project that's
you know about 30 some buildings it's a
big campus about 800 million the company
itself runs about 500
guys in the field that you work for but
so the if there is negligence it's the
company you work for
um
at this point the lawyers it's third
party you can't sue your own employer
um
so it's it's kind of looking like
excavators um i work in you know heavy
concrete as far as foundation wise
and what seems to have happened is you
know we came in the same day that they
dug out dirt to do some you know
foundation work and then the foundation
blew out and buried me so
that's uh
as far as that so you think long term
with your injury you'll recover enough
to go back to doing your job
uh i do um the doctor already said you
know i i tore three rotator cuffs and a
bicep so overhead stuff's probably not
really gonna be in there but i love the
industry i love working with people you
know this
is
it's not my plans to move away from this
type of injury that kind of answers the
question and so you'll be back to making
an income
similar to you used to make
but yeah there's workers comp and
workers comp and disability will cover
you until then
yeah workers comp they're getting to me
with within a hundred dollars in my
paycheck where i was so so
mathematically if i'm understanding how
and here's what i'm trying to get my
head around
mathematically if i'm understanding you
go from disability workers comp to back
to working again over some period of
time
and you're going to have the same income
as you had before the accident
everything's going to be running right
along so any settlement that you get
would be to cover uh any more surgeries
that you have to do
or any other injuries that you anything
you have to do regarding the injury
or
um
it's just gravy you don't really need
the money your life is going to go on
like it was before the accident
and the money that you get
mathematically speaking will be just to
uh
will just cause you to have a
gravy on the biscuit to you know to have
a little extra right
right so my point my point is how long
do you wait for money that you didn't
need anyway as long as you need to wait
to get the maximum amount
and so as far as your attorneys that are
advising you on this negligence lawsuit
can tell you what the timeline looks
like and if it's four years
it really doesn't matter because you're
going to have the same income anyway
and you're going to be moving right
along am i missing something
right i was just kind of thinking you
know if it's something crazy like a
million dollars you know is there a
timeline that you wait to let that kind
of soak in no or it doesn't really
matter it's already that timeline's
already been used up by then no you're
you're going to you're going to have a
long timeline
they don't give up a million dollars a
few years they don't give up a million
dollars easy it's going to take a while
and remember this and you don't have to
have it to eat yeah and the idea of a
settlement yeah the idea of a settlement
is to make you whole
not a
it's not a scratch-off ticket it's not a
you didn't hit a lottery ticket right
and so right you might get a million
dollars but you just said it um in
passing this is going to cost you so
this is going to shave some of some of
your life off right um this is gonna
affect you 20 years from now with a hip
replacement or 30 years for the knee
replay right so you want to bank some of
that stuff and be smart about it don't
think oh cool we can buy ferraris now
right or now we can buy a house with it
yeah not even um so i would continue
your life as if you weren't getting a
settlement and then if you get one it's
just extra money that's my point
and then then the timeline doesn't
matter as much you're not waiting to buy
a house on this settlement you're not
waiting to do something on this
settlement because you're not waiting on
the settlement you're moving on with
your life man i'm sorry for what you
have i'm sorry tim glad you're terrible
[Music]
[Music]
the housing market over the last couple
of years has been
unique
it's been great great
yeah house prices have gone up like a
rocket hungry buyers are bouncing on
homes now there's a plot twist the fed
is up the ante to raise the federal
funds rate for the first time in three
years we're seeing mortgage rates go up
as as a result
and uh
that's got a lot of you worried about
higher mortgage rates and maybe even a
recession
might make buying or selling a home more
difficult so let's just take a breath
turn off the news
let's get a little perspective
a whole lot goes into buying or selling
a home
not just market conditions and not just
the news and not just mortgage rates
anytime you're looking to buy or sell a
home you need to do your homework
team up with a pro who really knows
their stuff
so if you want more info on how the fed
works why this interest rate hike or
happened and what you can do about it a
bunch of spin from the media
head on over to ramsey solutions dot com
slash rates you can also go to ramsey
solutions dot com slash agent to talk to
someone from our endorsed local
providers program these ramsey trusted
real estate agents know how to handle
market changes and they'll help you
make smart
and informed decisions
that's ramsey solutions dot com slash
agent
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five thank you for
joining us michael is with us michael's
in la hey michael welcome to the ramsay
show
hey dave and john how's it going good
man how can we help
yeah so um i'm 24 years old um i make
170 000 a year
i mean you know the company i work for
is great you know culture's great
everything about it's great work 24 and
you make 170 a year what do you do
so i work in fulfillment and logistics
what do you fulfill
no he legit oh oh
so yeah supply chain um
yes exactly exactly so a lot of like
e-commerce um
uh yeah basically like qvc is as a
typewriter you are aware that you are
unicorn right
uh i i guess so sir 24 year olds that
make 170 000 a year do not grow on trees
dude
that's very impressive very impressive
you must be very very good at what you
do that's incredible
thank you thank you so much it's an
honor coming from you guys
um so yeah let me come up with the the
problem so
you know all my life i feel like i'm
still searching like for more and more
i'm great at my job
but i feel like i can do more
i'm gonna know what culture these days
company culture at least you know
i'm afraid of like leaving my company
um you know i've only been here for
eight months
but before this
this role
i was doing the same exact level same
i'm a director level uh currently right
now
um and and i feel like i can become a vp
level you know in the next you know six
months and
i just wanted some guidance you know am
i being too confident am i being too
hasty you know i feel like i want more i
feel like i want a larger scope i feel
like i want to do
um you know
be even better than i am right now um am
i wrong for for feeling that way or
looking to leave my company within like
six months
i
you're conflating a lot of things into a
single stream
right
um
why do you want to be a vice president
a little larger scope
okay why do you want to have larger
scope
i feel like i want to do more i want to
make more changes i want to
why uh
like
what what will you get
you want to make more changes what does
that mean like like i i want
like i guess the question would why
would anyone want a better paying job or
why would anyone more
okay here's work to do i want to learn
that's a great question okay yes in
learning more that's just how you
conflate it a lot um
here's a you're 24 so here's a powerful
life lesson if you can learn this at 24
i didn't get it until i was probably 37
or 38
and it was a humbling smack in my face
okay
whatever job you get whatever person you
get to marry you whatever car you buy
whatever kid you have the second kid
third kid eighth kid
you go with you
and so that stirring you have that
feeling that sense of i'm just not i'm
i'm just not complete i'm just not
that's gonna go to your next job and
you're gonna get vice president and
you're gonna be within six months you'll
be thinking
okay uh where can i be ceo and then i
want to be a ceo
it's you're going to keep running and
running and running until you decide
you're all right where you are and i'm
going to learn this stuff now here's the
other side to that
we need really really ambitious peach
people in our culture right now we got a
lot of big problems that we need fixed
you by the way fix the supply chain what
are you doing they're paying you 170
grand and
there's a lot of big problems so i want
people to be ambitious i want people to
start businesses and work really hard
and grow big businesses to help a lot of
the challenges in the country i just
want the leaders in those companies to
know
that
those big paychecks and that vice
presidency it's not going to fix you
it's not going to make you feel less
restless and you sound a lot like me who
the moment i got a job i was applying
for the other job and then as soon as i
got that job i was thinking about where
am i going to go next
and it wasn't until i landed and said
i got to fix my relationships with
myself with my past with my family with
my friends and then i have this state of
peace and here's what's beautiful about
it
then i could go do anything
and then i ended up in the job of a
lifetime and after that i got the job of
another lifetime after that right you
see what i'm saying
you're right that makes total sense what
you're chasing is peace and you will not
get that a job title or a dollar amount
yeah shut up
holy
going back to your first um oh you want
to talk dave sorry you're fine go ahead
okay going back to your first thing like
like is it wrong like for example i
won't find peace and i'll make it to vp
and then see all one day but is that
wrong to like like is it wrong to
realize that i need peace at the ceo
level like oh like i i need peace but oh
i'm the ceo making 250 a year like like
is that wrong to like go as a style
you're attaching a moral construct
to
to a linear condition
all right now what i mean is that okay
this okay
ambition is not wrong
growth is not wrong
changing jobs is not wrong
doing it to try to become complete
because you weren't complete at the last
place
is bad medicine
it's not going to work in other words
john john as a talk he does says the
title of the talk is winning doesn't
make you well
right so you sound very smart and very
legitimately not illegitimately
ambitious
but the fact that you're struggling with
the part of you they're struggling with
is this wrong as if it's a moral
construct that it's bad to be ambitious
or it's bad to have growth or it's bad
to make a big income or it's bad to move
up the ladder it's bad to change jobs
none of those things are bad none of
them are good
they're ambivalent to the moral
construct
but ambition for ambition's sake
ambition so that i feel good about the
guy in the mirror you won't ever catch
him he keeps moving he's a bully in the
schoolyard he takes another step back
draws another line the sand says when
you step across this line then you'll be
happy and then when you step across this
line then you'll be happy and then when
you step across this line then you'll be
happy and happiness is not aligned
across
right
and so it's not bad nothing you have
done
physically morally
is in a moral construct that is bad it's
all good
why you're doing some of it
maybe i'm gonna guess john is listening
to you michael my estimate would be that
20 of why you're doing this
is brokenness 80 is all good reasons
right but you're piling them all in
together and the brokenness part is
making you question the whole idea
so let me let me tell you a
shape-shifter in my career i got a job
way over my head at a real young age
very much like you i was pretty good at
what i did
um and they took care of me and it
wasn't until i got around people that
were one step ahead of me the vice
presidents
and then i realized oh they know this
stuff really well they had something i
didn't have we all had knowledge they
had wisdom
i'd love to see you stay put for a year
for two years and learn the business and
not just how logistics work but how
people work and how the cycle is going
to work through a recession and and get
some of that wisdom some of those scars
and strength and then you will be an
incredible vice president you go into
that stuff with confidence and wisdom
and peace
you are you're an incredible young guy
yeah
don't look for healing in movement
it's not there
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host in
the lobby of ramsey solutions you can
drop by and see us anytime if you'd like
we do the show from one to four central
time every day monday through friday
and um we'd love to have you there's
usually 50 to 200 folks sitting out here
it's completely free that's how much we
charge and that's how much it's worth so
thanks for coming and also we got a
great visitor center the cookies alone
are worth the price of free and so is
the free coffee it's worth the price of
free also in the lobby is our debt free
stage on that stage is jordan and sarah
hey guys welcome to the ramsey show
congratulations on being debt-free
thanks dave thank you where do you guys
live
just a little bit east of greensboro
north carolina cool welcome to nashville
and how much debt have you paid off
just over 169 thousand dollars love it
i'm going with 170 then okay so uh how
long did this take 15 months wow and
your range of income during that time we
started at 126 000 and went up to 185.
good good for you guys what do y'all do
for a living
uh well she's a teacher
and i own a photography and videography
real estate company oh very good very
good what do you teach special education
high school oh wow that's a brave soul
right there i'm proud of you we need you
back this is the harder job obviously
yeah definitely definitely what'd you do
today i took a picture of a building
what about you
wrangled 20k deal with parents all day
yeah oh the kids that's the blessing
it's the parents
oh wow way to go guys what kind of debt
was the 170 it was our mortgage you paid
off your ass all right look at the weird
people
congratulations weirdos thank you great
to go you guys loving being weird yep
how old are you two
uh i'm almost 39 and she's 30 77. all
right not even 40 years old what's the
house worth
uh it's
in the range of
400 420 somewhere around for you way to
go guys
very very cool well done how much is in
your retirement accounts
uh just about 100 right now good for you
so
you're on your way to baby steps
millionaire yeah good for y'all way to
go guys yeah
what got all this started 15 months ago
because you guys got fired up here
well it was during the pandemic
yeah i had i've always had this little
fear of always losing my house
apparently that's the thing that i just
wanted to make sure i provide for
her and our kids
um so you know kind of when the pandemic
hit that kind of sprung it in a little
bit and i was like i i this would be
awesome if our house was paid for just
in case
something happened did you ever have
that experience when you were a kid or
something or what no i just i i've just
always uh had a little bit of fear of
providing like i want to make sure i
provide good for you and so act of honor
yeah well done yeah i mean i'm very i'm
i'm
i'm very chivalrous i guess
um
she just shook her head
i love it
but yeah that's really what started it
is uh you know it would be it the
pandemic didn't really hit us too hard
um my company actually uh did pretty
well over the pandemic yeah um and uh
real estate with taking pictures of it
because nobody wanted to go actually
look at it with humans yeah it's a big
deal i mean 360 view virtual views all
that stuff went nuts that stuff picked
up a lot of people buying houses in this
area side unseen only with the drone
picks and the 360s yeah exactly
yeah as soon as that as soon as it
happened i was like we probably need to
start send as much money as we can to
the mortgage and
get it all taken care of might as well
get rid of that one less fear one less
thing to be afraid of exactly and the
house is paid for so
now that you did it
how's it feel was there that release you
were looking for uh yeah i mean it's
kind of it's already kind of sank in a
little bit but uh you know the the the
last payment
of clicking well we're really clicking a
button is calling the bank and saying we
need
you know them to pay off the last 30
grand um you know that was a that was a
very cool moment and uh we really we
really enjoyed that yeah that's fun and
it's fun telling people our house is
paid off we don't go around wearing
t-shirts saying our house is paid off
but when when that conversation when the
summer conversation comes up that's just
get t-shirts to say weirdos see what
happens
dave's weirdos guys that's it i love it
good for you guys man i'm so proud of
you thank you so proud of you what's the
first big thing you're gonna do now that
the house is paid for well we've started
putting money towards going on a 10-year
anniversary wedding trip where are you
going to go
montego bay yeah montana yeah nice
that's going to be in that's going to be
in august and
uh it's not really uh it's not really a
thing of oh gosh we got to pay for this
when we get back and or anything it's
just
all right ready to go write a check and
enjoy it yeah it's a beautiful area
you'll love it yeah looking forward to
it excellent excellent good for you guys
yeah
so okay how did you get connected up to
ramsay stuff sorry john
well um i don't know if this is a really
funny story but when me and her were
dating uh i guess i forced her to listen
to one of your podcasts while we were in
the car um
not only is he cheerful but he's
romantic yeah
his his car his rules yeah yeah nothing
says i love you like hey let's listen to
this guy on the way to our date no
smooth jazz no old
pop songs let's get a hillbilly on the
radio
she was pretty cool but i wanted to make
sure she was going to be debt-free at
some point
[Laughter]
man your chivalry is shining through my
friend but but i had more debt than she
did so it was yes um but yeah i mean we
i kind of knew about you for a while and
i guess when she heard uh one of the
podcasts she
kind of picked it up and started reading
the book and
and it just kind of all started from
there all right very cool good for you
guys what was the um who sat down with
who and had the hard conversation about
let's let's let's suck it up for a year
or two and pay this thing off i think it
was more me um
i had just gone back to work after
staying at home with my youngest for a
few months and i was like well you know
i'm back at work i'm back at making a
paycheck let's
let's just do this let's instead start
sending in the extra money
at first um i think that was back in the
spring right when kovit hit and he said
well let's wait until the fall starts
when you you know because in the
summertime i don't get a paycheck he
said let's wait till the fall you know
get the money coming in and then let's
start throwing it at the house
when you added it up did you think it
was going to take 15 months or longer no
our first
estimate was it was going to be 18
months
and then there was but there's obviously
a couple good months in there and you
know when 2020 hit when the government
started sending money just because the
pandemic
all we did was just take that money and
just put it towards the mortgage and
and that helped a little bit john you
and i paid off their house
thanks america we didn't ask for it but
they sent it so thank you america
the taxpayer dollars at work that was
nice of us dave that was nice of us you
guys are fun way to go y'all amazing
thank you so proud of you very very very
well done all right what do you tell
people the secret to getting out of debt
is
um definitely
budgeting having a plan and having the
same goals
yeah the budget is definitely the thing
uh she's she's all of that she's that
budget person
so uh her her her
making sure we stay on that that's the
that's the main thing for me
very good good stuff i'm so proud of
y'all it's awesome great work all right
we got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you that's the next chapter in your
story for sure you're on your way
probably 45 year old millionaires i mean
that's what
it looks like right now or less yeah
good for y'all also i'm going to give
you a ramsay plus financial peace
university one year certificate to get
you guys in for a year subscribed if you
haven't been through the class you can
go through it if you have then give it
to somebody the same the same with the
total money makeover book we're going to
give you one of those we're going to
load you up on goodies to give away and
to enjoy both
and uh so well done very very very proud
of you all right let's bring the kiddos
in what are their names and ages
uh
good we have cooper who is almost seven
and then remington who is three all
right cooper and remington good stuff
good americans there i like them
patriotic we need to salute while we're
doing this good stuff all right jordan
and sarah cooper and remington
greensboro north carolina 170 000 paid
off in 15 years and not even 40 and
their house is paid for
making 126 to 185 count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream all right three
two one we're debt-free
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and those two little munchkins will
never know
oh
a house with a mortgage can you live in
a debt-free house and he's not even as
tall as your knee
it's awesome man
it's awesome i think all parents are
just kind to one another
man
amazing all parents don't have money
fights and live on a budget together and
have shared goals it happens at our
house so it must be everywhere wow
changing society one bit free house at a
time this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture today deuteronomy 28 12
the lord will open to you his good
treasure the heavens
to give the rain to your land in its
season and to bless all the work of your
hand you shall lend to many nations but
you shall not borrow
stephen covey said our most important
financial asset is our own capacity to
earn
that's true because your most powerful
wealth building tool
is your income thank you for joining us
america so john what do you think is
happening
in the culture
when we were going through the pandemic
and people were quarantined and lost
their jobs and others were
in the plexiglass business and having
the best year of their whole freaking
lives
um
you know some businesses were just
booming
and others were just gone
just went to nothing
and
that happened inside the building here i
mean we had in the entire live events
team
had to sit down there was no live events
when we lay them off they're still here
and we're doing events again now but
um
then we had other areas that just boomed
and we made more money than we thought
we'd ever make in some of these other
areas and so in our case inside ramsey
we had a really good year in 2020 much
better than we thought we were going to
when the world was coming to an end in
march
um
and uh much more than it was originally
budgeted we had a better than budget
year
uh but not i mean it didn't just
i mean we didn't just the skies didn't
open but other places the sky's open and
they had
whoa like that guy with his drone
business and real estate pictures his
business went crazy
and he didn't do anything but good
things he wasn't anything wrong but
there was a sense of
like you can't talk about it if you're
doing good because times are bad we have
a culture that is addicted to bad news
and
we we even have this day with our close
friends um
we don't call our friend when something
great happens to us maybe one or two of
them hey this thing happened that was
really great kid got to play like my
wife and i our marriage is great
we just don't have a cultural ethos
towards that and if you happen to be
doing well when things are you better
just keep that to yourself and then it
just got magnified and what's what's
strange is
most of the people who did really well
during the pandemic were helping their
community they happened to have a
business that was in service of other
people like uh uh
door dash or delivery or whatever right
and man i i i like to beat that drum
dave that we've got to be able to share
the tough stuff together but we've got
to be able to share the good stuff too
man
well i mean
it feels like you always talk about um i
kind of want to put in the same bucket
with
um
okay i
you know so and so went through this
horrible calamity
with cancer treatments and everything
else uh and i broke my leg yep no i
didn't but i mean you know but and you
always say don't compare your thing to
their thing yeah you're thinking you
broke your leg man it still hurts it's
awful still your leg hurt you know now i
understand it's not that it's not cancer
it's not 14 months of chemo it's not
going to lose my hair but minimizing
minimizing your thing isn't going to
help that's the thing and minimizing
the fact that you're successful doesn't
make that you're that you're making more
money than you're made in your life in
the middle of a bad time
when you're not doing anything wrong on
the contrary you're serving right um
hiding that as an act of shame doesn't
make the people that are financially
hurting get any better right that's the
bucket i wanted to put there you go yeah
and in fact you can become a lighthouse
to your community yeah showing that it
can be done that's right or a here's
what this could look like or here's an
idea or fill in the blank right yeah i
mean you know i
you know uh
we talked these travel nurses oh man
i've had several of them on the show
and they made like a half a million
dollars cleaned up man they did all
right half a million dollars when i'm
made in one year and another one another
one didn't even travel but she worked
two jobs were you on with me that girl
had 90 hours she's working 90 hours yeah
and she made like 380 000 bucks and she
was working two
40-hour jobs yeah yeah she's cleaning up
man we saw teachers who were teaching
and then they'd get right off of work
and go immediately into driving and then
the next morning they were up driving
uber and they just people worked really
hard all suddenly looked up and they
made an extra hundred thousand dollars
and that message during the time that
some other folks were legitimately
suffering financially absolutely but it
doesn't minimize their suffering
for you to hide your joy your success
under a bushel right
all right how's your light under a
bushel that's right it doesn't it
doesn't now if you're an arrogant idiot
about it then yes like
look at you know you you know you're
running poor people down or something
that's not the point there's idiots
everywhere but if you you know
there is a thing in these uh
one group of these trolls that um
that like any time you say that hey
listen like i said on fox news during
that time that they gave them like they
came out with a fourth round of money or
something and they're they're acting
like the whole world has changed because
biden's sending out thirteen hundred
dollars and i said if thirteen hundred
dollars changes your life you don't have
a life oh you're struggling you're
struggling more than you know what i got
i got 16 days
of trolling dave ramsey hates poor
people uh yeah you don't understand
you're you're too cool you think 1300
isn't any money dude mathematically if
1300 changes your life you do not have a
life mathematically that's not a poor
people run down thing that's an
arithmetic thing but man i got hammered
yeah i got destroyed entire reddit
threads going after ramsey and people
playing the clip over and over and over
and some of these wealth inequalities
morons retweeting the thing and all this
stuff as if i hate poor people i've
spent my entire life helping people that
were broke right but i mean
that so that that's why people couldn't
do it they can't say i'm winning
financially because you're shaming poor
people so the the flip side of that is
this
i have to here's a great example um
and you and i have talked about this i
the day that i got the call that my
first book made the best seller list i
thought my boss jeremy breeland i
thought he was
pranking me i thought he was messing
with me right why we knew it was gonna
be number one no not this one the old
one the real okay i thought he was
messing with me okay and so he calls
yeah i did too that same day yeah
that same so i thought he's messed with
me i hung up and i thought whoa well
shortly after one of my closest friends
in the world the most stable friend i
have
said that uh the bank he worked for got
sold and i said so are you rich and he
goes no i think i'm out of a job and i
told him you can't be out of a job
you're the most stable guy i know
and so we talked through it but in that
phone call
he told me the hardest news i think i'm
unemployed
and i said well while we're on the phone
i just made the best seller list
and he i was able to sit with him in his
grief
and he's like dude you've been working
for this for so long i'm so proud of you
that people i've known you for a long
time behind closed doors and i'm gonna
get choked up here he celebrated my win
and i sat with him in the crap
and that's the same that's
and so what he didn't hear is my win as
somehow somehow taking from him and he
was able to go i'm glad that there's a
lot because he's not a freaking victim
that's right and so it's if i if i lost
my job and you had your best year ever
you having your best you ever doesn't
take from me in fact i could allow it to
inspire me to take another step out
there right yeah that's it that's the
way it should be and it flips right so
if but we've got this there's something
in this entitlement stuff are in this
cancel world i have to take from you in
order
you know if you say anything about
get up off your butt leave the cave kill
something and drag it home then you're
shaming poor people right which is quite
the opposite yeah
i'm teaching people how to not be poor
people you're giving them a set of
skills and strategies right yeah yeah i
mean i've been broke but i've never been
poor poor's a state of mind
you know and i've never been poor i've
been completely dead dog broke yeah
where i mean we got a bucket sitting on
the dadgum kitchen table and what
water's dripping off the
the light fixture i've been broke and i
don't know what that looks like i've and
i've also sat there with a fixture over
the light table was more than i made in
those other years
but i've been i've been poor i've had
that mindset of this is the way it's
always going to be right and it's taken
being around other people who have been
successful and who have worked really
hard and who have
opened businesses and they fill in the
blank
to go
i can be different i can do this
different but these guys that are doing
these free screams they're changed their
family tree because they believed that's
right they had hope they had a picture
of it but if i change
these
transactions
regardless of what they my my old
neighborhood said regardless of what the
tapes my uncle said
the the college professor said you're
never going to amount to anything i did
it anyway and uh my college professor my
senior year dropped his glasses down his
nose said ramsay you got a firm grasp on
the obvious
and so i went and made millions of
dollars proving him to be right
i sell the obvious for a living i sell
common sense for a living and i'm good
at it so there you go i help people
celebrate people's victories man we need
a culture that shines lights celebrate
their victory sit with them in their
grief and celebrate their victories that
puts this hour of the ramsey show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime we'll be back in
the meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus the ramsay show did
you know over 18 million people listen
to the ramsay show every week a lot of
those people listen on one of our 600
plus radio stations across the country
to find a station near you go to
ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you